Gráfica encontrando las raíces y el vértice de la
parábola "y" es igual a "x" cuadrada más 4x -12 ,
y bueno lo primero que nos piden es encontrar las raíces
pero, cuando las personas hablan de encontrar las raíces, a lo que se están refiriendo es a encontrar los puntos en donde mi parábola
intersecta al eje de las "x", y bueno cuando una función
intersecta al eje de las "x", lo que estamos haciendo es tomar a "y"  igual a 0. Para encontrar dónde
intersecta mi parábola al eje de las "x", hay que hacer "y" igual a 0. Y entonces me queda "x" cuadrada más
4x -12 igual a 0 y bueno esta es una ecuación
cuadrática. Y si te das cuenta tenemos un coeficiente de 1 al lado de la "x" cuadrada, y por lo tanto podemos
factorizar esta expresión de una manera sencilla. Estoy buscando 2 números que sumados me den 4 y que
multiplicados me den -12 y esos números son el
6 y el 2, el 6 y el -2. El 6 y el -2 funcionan es decir esto lo puedo
factorizar como "x" más 6 que a su vez multiplica a "x" -2
esta es la factorización de "x "cuadrada  más 4x -12  y esto a su vez es igual a 0.
Y bueno si tengo 2 cosas multiplicadas iguales a 0,
entonces o la primera es 0 o la segunda es 0 y si "x" más 6 es igual a cero,
entonces si restó 6 de ambos lados de la ecuación me queda que "x" es igual a -6.
Mientras que de este otro lado si sumo 2 de ambos lados de la ecuación, me queda que "x" es igual a 2 y ya
con esto, tengo los valores de "x" en donde mi parábola intersecta al eje de las "x", es decir mis raíces de esta ecuación
cuadrática que era justo lo que quería, y bueno entonces voy a poner 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
aquí es el .-6,0, y bueno aquí es el primer punto en donde ésta parábola
intersecta el eje de las "x". Mientras que por otro lado tengo "x" igual a 2, esta es mi segunda
raíz y es también el punto en donde interceptamos al eje de las "x" justo aquí en el
2,0 va a pasar por ahí mi parábola y además,
intersecta al eje de las "x". Y después me pide encontrar el vértice de ésta parábola,
y para contra el vértice de esta parábola lo que tengo que hacer es fijarme en el punto medio de estos 2,
y hay varias formas de hacerlo. Sin embargo para mí
esta es la forma más fácil de encontrar el vértice de una parábola, dado que ya tenemos donde
intercepta el eje de las "x", lo que voy a buscar su eje de simetría y su eje de simetría
pasa por el punto medio de estos 2, y más aún el valor de "x" del punto medio de estos 2,
es el valor del vértice de mi parábola que estoy buscando.
Así que vamos a sacar el punto medio en "x" entre -6 y 2
y me queda -6 más 2 entre 2, lo cual me da -2, y ahora hay que sacar el valor de "y"
y para eso lo que voy a hacer es sustituir el valor de "x" igual a -2 en mi función y me va a quedar,
"y" es igual a -2 al cuadrado lo cual me da 4 positivo,
4x -12 lo cual me da -8 -12 y esto ¿A cuánto es igual?
4 - 8 me da -4, - 4 - 12 me da -16.
Perfecto ya tengo el vértice de mi parábola, el vértice de mi  parábola está en el punto - 2,-16
y es más vamos a graficarlo. Aquí tenemos al vértice
y entonces déjenme poner todos los puntos necesarios para llegar hasta el -16,-7,-8, -9,- 10
-11, -12, -13, -14. -15 y -16 u ¡Uf!
quedamos bastante abajo de lo que teníamos en nuestro plano
cartesiano, sin embargo no te preocupes aquí tengo el vértice. Es más déjenme ponerlo por aquí por que creo que no me quedo parejo,
aquí voy a tener yo al vértice y entonces éste sigue siendo mi eje de las "y" y este es el punto -2, -16
el cual es el punto mínimo de mi parábola, por lo tanto voy a intentar hacer una gráfica de esta parábola
más o menos así.
Aquí está la gráfica de esta parábola.
Una vez que ya tengo el vértice y además los puntos de intersección con el eje de las "x" que por cierto, además
también sé que mi eje de simetría es justo este que estoy pintando ahorita, es decir donde "x" vale -2.
Y bueno también estoy pensando en que había otras formas de encontrar el vértice.
Otra forma de encontrar el valor de "x" es aplicando la fórmula que hace tiempo habíamos encontrado,
en donde decíamos que el valor de "x" del vértice es igual a -"b" entre 2a
pero, "b" vale 4 por lo tanto me quedaría
- 4 entre -2 por 1, lo cual me da 2 y entonces -4 entre 2 nos dan -2 y otra vez
obtengo el mismo valor. Y bueno de hecho también hay una tercera forma de encontrar el vértice de esta parábola, y es  fijándome en esta expresión
y completando el binomio al cuadrado perfecto.
Es decir me queda "y" es igual a "x" cuadrada más 4x y voy a poner hasta acá el -12, y ahora voy a
completar el binomio el cuadrado perfecto de esta expresión que tengo aquí.
"x" cuadrada más 4x ¿Más qué es un binomio al cuadrado perfecto? Y bueno para que sea un binomio cuadrado perfecto,
hay que sumarle 4 pero, a su vez también hay que restarle 4 para que se mantenga la igualdad.
Y toda esta expresión que tengo de amarillo, es lo mismo que poner
"x" más 2 elevado al cuadrado. Date cuenta que esto es "x" cuadrada más 4x más 4, por lo tanto lo que estoy haciendo es
completando el binomio al cuadrado perfecto, y del otro lado me queda -4 -12 lo cual es -16
y bueno aquí tengo una expresión
equivalente a la misma función con la que empecé pero, aquí hay una gran diferencia y quiero que te des cuenta en esto.
"x" más 2 siempre va a ser mayor o igual que 0 y por lo tanto el valor más pequeño que puede tomar esta función, es cuando
esta expresión "x" más 2 elevado al cuadrado es 0, por que es 0 - 16 me quedaría
"y" igual a -16 por que cualquier otro valor que me salga "x" más 2 elevado al cuadrado nos va a dar algo
positivo y entonces cuando yo le reste
16 me va a salir algo más grande que - 16 por lo tanto cuando "y" vale -16,
es decir aquí en el vértice de mi parábola, es donde yo tengo el punto mínimo y entonces esto pasa cuando
"x" más 2 tiene que ser igual a 0. Lo que estoy haciendo es esta parte igual a 0 y entonces
despejando "x" me queda que "x" es igual a -2 y ¿Qué crees?
Encontré otra vez el vértice de mi parábola y estas 3 formas, son formas equivalentes de llegar al mismo resultado.